do you think then that a man should have
a say if a woman has an abortion or not
no i think once it's got to that stage
and you've had unprotected sex with the
person
i think that act and it turns into uh an
embryo
you're you're beholden it's happening if
she says it's happening it's happening
the thing is the thing is i actually
i'm not someone who's necessarily for
abortion but the point is
you decided to have sex with a man who
didn't want to have children and so now
that you're
forcing him to have children you can't
then complain if he doesn't want to pay
for it is is the point
she's actually
those are two different things to me but
the figures
the law enforcement wanting it to happen
i think it should be law that he does
pay oh god no
what i don't think it should be do you
not think that's a little bit of a
double standard that is madness the
child is here
no it wasn't though but not not if she
got no no but she's but
so i would i'm not really like pro-life
in that way i think you have your
choices but if she has decided i'm not
going to have an abortion
and the child comes about i think two
parents are then responsible for raising
the child that's being financially
it's your body your choice yeah
but if i don't have a choice in that
matter like my i'm like well your choice
was no no no i don't have a choice let's
look let's stop playing this game
no no that's not playing this game i
don't have a choice because i do not
want that kid i chose to have sex with
you i didn't choose to have an offspring
and this year you chose to have an
offspring yeah why are you forcing me to
have to pay for it because i do not want
it's not right the same way i'm not
going to tell you
get rid of that baby and get out your
body or i can't force you to get rid of
that baby you shouldn't be able to force
me to have to pay for a child that i do
not want yeah that's not the same
they know
this is very disingenuous to say that
because
you know they don't you know they don't
because women can have sex without
having children and that we see that's
happening right rampantly but yet men
don't apparently have that same right
but it's happened so you had said that's
the point that's the point it's
happening you paid ratio
so i i shouldn't necessarily be
forced to pay for i think i think once
the child comes about you have to pay
but i think that would make sense if you
made it equal
so if a woman gets to opt like like she
was saying like if a woman gets the
option to opt out of motherhood
shouldn't a man have the option to opt
out of fatherhood why does only a woman
get that say
because the child is here now so so
because of the woman's choice okay so
the woman has the choice yes and she's
gone through it and the child is like
six choices i forgot about adoption
okay so
the child is now here yeah and the man
has decided i don't want to be a parent
but correct so then should the state
pay for that child
no the woman should
because she made the choice to have it
when she could have had an abortion but
then earlier on you guys went through
all of the stats of the single parent
household right how that actually leads
to the detriment of the child yes
if it was so the child should be
punished for the woman and the man's
choices she'd still be in a single place
if it was up to me it would be equal
abortion wouldn't be legal and the man
well i don't child support wouldn't be a
thing
but i think it should be equal if i
think you can say to a woman you should
have an abortion and then it takes place
is what you're saying no no i'm saying
i'm saying i don't believe in abortion i
if it was up to me i wouldn't have it
but since it's legal i mean i think like
that's not going to change anytime soon
it's already legal i'm saying it should
be equal
so a man should be able to financially
opt out of a child
if
if a woman can opt out of being a mother
okay
to make it equal okay so that
and you're saying that solely then if
it's the woman that's saying i'm gonna
have the child all of the financial
responsibility should just go on her yes
and the state shouldn't get involved to
help yes because she had six options
because even if she has the kids she can
still
give it up for adoption i'll give you a
story my mom was 17. she got pregnant by
my dad right and instead of they didn't
have money they're in college and they
gave that kid up for adoption and he's
like 30 years he's he's married now he
has his old life ahead of him
and so he was raised in a two-parent
household
and so i'm saying why can't she do that
okay
yeah i fundamentally don't agree with
that i think that when the child is here
that both parents should be right so i'm
saying she could find a family to do it
without a parent also isn't it's like
you give these things like there isn't
any emotional ramifications
that's that's it was a really tough
decision for my mom yeah i'm saying it
was really important to do that right
but i'm saying that's selfish
you've brought you've brought your
anecdote into this but when you look at
the care system of how many people in
the uk care system go to prison it is
doing red or black that i don't think
adoption is viable you don't have to do
adoption but what you can do is pick a
better man to make a kid with yeah i
want to go on go on birth control i'm
saying there's six layers i agree with
that i'm saying had i'm not saying it
has to be adoption i'm saying choice
choice choice choice choice and choice
so why can't a man financially opt out
of being a father but because i think
all of those choices that the woman can
go through are not the same as the
financial burden yeah i hear that
they're very different you were talking
about the ramifications of you know
being putting a child in adoption but
again
you're not considering ramifications of
growing up knowing your dad didn't want
you
yeah that can destroy your men yeah
that's true 100
because like you're like the child's
here now but this is not amazon prime
bro it takes like nine and a half months
for the youth to come or something like
that do you know what i mean it's not
like he just turns up like the payment
comes out and then
it doesn't happen so should
no no i'm not getting my head around
anything if i tell you like at the time
if we find out that you're pregnant and
i say yo like
yeah i'm saying i'm not ready for your
dad i don't want to be a dad maybe
financially i don't feel i can do it
many i'm not in the right space you told
me now we're having a baby
it's my body my choice but a man can say
yo what is my money my choice i know i'm
just like if you don't understand you
know that guy probably doesn't want to
be a dad you know that straight away
but then you are you got to still force
him to you don't even know his situation
whether he's financially stable whether
he's in the right mental state to have a
child how could he how is that morally
right though giving me like loads of and
i'm saying
that is blanket wants a child but how is
that really right though because like
i'm not talking about morals i'm talking
about so the moral implication would be
your offspring is here
you said before
when the man is is is has to be held
accountable for for taking part in
having sex yeah
morally he should be there to look after
his kid as someone who participated in
them in creation of this child yeah so
how can you then morally say that oh my
morals are correct and saying i'm going
to force this man to have to be a father
though doesn't want to be a father
how is one because the child the child
is going to be here now and i think as a
man
and you have your child what about you
as a woman
well
i would not do that but for other women
if i'm going to advocate for other women
in that position
they may have all of their their
emotional isms as to why they don't want
to it may be it may be a moral issue for
them they're like i can't have an
abortion this is my child i have to go
through with this this is where we are
i think as a man if your offspring is
here you should pay for that child i
understand what you're saying because
i'm not necessarily i don't necessarily
agree with abortion i'm just saying to
you the moment you decide to disregard
all the six different options you have
and say you're having this child
i should be able to say well that's fine
but i'm not gonna do that all the time
you can also i'm talking about from my
point of view legally you should pay but
i don't know what do you mean many
dollars on that they don't pay for their
kids but it's not it's not like for the
lord the lord
to force me to lose and i think the law
is correct in this instance
i'm saying there's a difference between
more like if if my brother got a girl
pregnant i i think he should take care
of the kid morally but i think there's a
difference between that i'm putting a
gun to a guy's head and saying you must
take you must pay for the child well
nobody has a gun to their head well i
mean sort of legally you can go to jail
for not paying child support even if you
actually don't have the money to pay you
you could say
but yeah not over here you can't okay
you you know that's it's still in the
west you know in the western world yes
but no but you only will go to prison if
you do have the means and you haven't
paid no even if you don't have means you
will still
in america yeah in america so over here
i i have numerous friends they have not
received a penny from their baby fathers
they have decided that that they're not
going to pay i think that you should pay
yeah and you should want to pay as a man
the whole the whole point is that
legally like i don't think legally i
think sorry if women legally have the
choice to not be a mother i think men
should legally have the choice not to be
a father
i don't i don't really agree with women
not being able to have i don't really
agree with women not
women having the choice to not be a
mother but i'm just saying if they're
going to do that it should be equal yeah